it's
fitting that i present this tribute to
andy
uh using zoom technology because we used
to both
commiserate that we spent far more time
on telecons as astronomers and on
telescopes
and i really just wanted to express my
deep
love admiration and affection for andy
and i still haven't gotten over
this loss and i never will i think about
him every day
and that's not likely to change
i spent a lot of time here in my office
talking about ideas
and hopes and dreams and uh it's really
just
devastating that he's not here he's not
here to continue
this uh lovely relationship that we had
and
really came to me as a gift i met andy
through his mother
of all places of mikvah which is a
jewish ritual bath
that was attempting to be being
constructed in san diego
about eight or nine years ago and i
didn't meet andy i met his mother
you know so he wasn't even present when
i first learned how incomparably
brilliant he was i learned that from his
mother andy
uh and naturally i was uh kind of
a little bit suspicious of the praise
coming out of uh such an uh
obviously unbiased observer his mother
uh who's also very lovely and gracious
and effusive and and i could tell
instantly
that if he was anything like her uh that
it would be
uh cool if i could actually get andy to
come to san diego
on a permanent basis so he started to
scheme about it
and he was my friend and
the universe was his laboratory and
that's why i choose to give this tribute
out here in the darkness
with the sky up behind me because he
literally used the entire
universe as his place to do tests
i remember my first visit with andy
at the mit co-op and he was trying to
explain the nuances of quantum mechanics
to me
which as a physician i was still
having a little bit of trouble getting
and he valiantly tried to explain those
things to me over the years
but really engaged me on his
view of physics which i come to
see as calm acceptance of the unknowable
i feel so lucky to have called
andy friedman a friend and a colleague
at the clark center
and i still
you know can't believe um that we don't
have him with us and that we don't
have many more years of talking about
future projects
and coming up with ideas for new
programs and
and just having the kind of
warm funny delightful conversations he
was known for
you know after a clark center event or
or over some rubios on campus
um so i just want to you know again
send my deepest condolences to kristen
and to andy's parents and to everyone in
his family
and all of us in
academia and the world of science
that mourn his loss and
and miss his his warm-heartedness his
expansive imagination his willingness to
collaborate and entertain
wild ideas and
and you know especially for us with
clark as our namesake
just how much joy and inspiration he
took from science fiction
um but from all of the arts and in music
especially and i actually wanted to
include some of the skills and talents
that angie andy uniquely possessed
in my group's research and i knew i
needed somebody with
his exceptional capabilities as an
observer
using optical telescopes to make the
next move into
studying the foundational aspects of
whether or not the universe has certain
properties that everyone assumes it does
have namely that it's symmetric that it
has
certain certain relationships between
the speed of light
and the time of of travel over which
light journeys to our telescopes
so his mother made the match and we
start to talk the next time he was in
san diego
and we were just instantly became bonded
we became friends instantly
and eventually we found a plan for him
to come to san diego not only as a
scientist
as a postdoc or something like that but
actually as a research scientist which
meant that he could mentor students and
kind of act as a professor
without all the annoying grading and so
forth that we have to deal with as
as faculty members so it really suited
him well because he's in now he was a
natural teacher
said i can't even talk about him without
slipping into the present tense he's
forever so vivacious and vibrant in my
mind
we also began a partnership which would
last for many years and that was
something we ended up calling in a
version of the three tenors we called it
the three jews it was me david bryn
and andy and we presented uh sold out
but i point out there were free science
talks at the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination there there are some ideas
very speculative
in these versions of string theory where
you have these large extra dimensions
like these brain world scenarios that
david was mentioning um we have some
evidence that's very
you know intriguing this is the idea of
so-called dark matter
uh it seems like there's a lot of
missing mass in the universe
and some people speculate that one way
of explaining this is that
it could be due to the gravitational
influence of other brains
uh farther away i don't know if this is
correct but that's the kind of a thing
where
maybe there actually already is evidence
out there for other universes
and we just need the theoretical and
philosophical framework in order to
really
elucidate that one always feels that
there's
going to be more time and i always felt
that there would be more time to do more
things with andy to
have more conversations and have more of
the wonderful
three physicists gatherings that we've
done on occasion
for the public um so this is a terrible
blow
the biggest concepts in physics the
arrow of time
the nature of the multiverse free will
etc and eventually he ended up
you know really wonderfully leading a
talk about his
project the cosmic bell test that was
later turned into
a pbs special anova about this search
for
you know certain properties of of
quantum mechanics that
einstein himself referred to referred to
as spooky action at a distance
and involved things like entanglement
and the sort of fitting because we all
are still
deeply entangled with andy i feel so
lucky
to have called andy friedman a friend
and a colleague at the clark center
and i still
you know can't believe um that we don't
have him with us
and that we don't have many more years
of
talking about future projects and coming
up with
ideas for new programs and and just
having the kind of warm funny
delightful conversations he was known
for
one of the highlights of my you know
time with andy was when the two of us
presented along with professor shelly
wright
of ucsd we presented at comic-con
and you know i really saw andy in his
glory at that time he was just
beaming he was in front of his beloved
wife kristen
his parents and i i think
um you know his friends from san diego
and it was just a delight to have him
uh shining and and sparkling so
luminously
one of the highest things that i ever
can say that i was able to do is to make
him laugh
he was he had this incredibly drawl
sense of humor
and he would say things under his breath
and and you just
have to stifle a laugh in the middle of
a talk or
just his running commentary he was
really
delightfully mercurial and it's just
such a such a dream of a friend of a
scientist
such a deep scientist only cared about
doing the most
challenging tasks in all of science the
foundation of reality of quantum
mechanics
of relativity of astrophysics
and he did it all with augusto and a
passion
that was irrepressible andy was a
scientist an astrophysicist
and a vigorously imaginative one he
helped to advance our knowledge of the
extent of the universe
with his work on supernovas but also
deep quantum aspects that
combine the uh application of quasars at
opposite ends of the universe to study
whether or not
the universe is deeply entangled it's
not everybody who gets to
connect the very large with the very
small and he did
uh did things a lot better than i could
do in many ways especially with his
patients with undergraduates and and his
keen sense of
uh to detail attention to detail that he
always exhibited
so it's with a great a great sadness
that i have to recount this because it's
almost impossible
to conceive of him not being here and so
i can always uh can always count
on on my uh on my relationship with him
my faith that
someday we will be all together reunited
in a better place uh but for now the
earth is a lot
poorer and heaven is a lot richer
because he's there
so i miss him tremendously and i
uh i want to express my
deep love and admiration for him and for
his family
and um and just tell him that anytime i
look up at the cosmos i think about him
he's really truly a giant humble
yet hilarious astronomer
that that i had such a privilege to work
with and the only regret i had is that
it was too short
but the thing i'll never forget about
him is
is how he made me laugh and how he made
me think
and i'll never forget that here in the
sky
we've had the comet neo-wise this summer
and as it's just appeared back
out into the darkness i think that
that's andy
taking his flight for us uh back out to
the universe
carrying his spirit i thought that
neowise was a brilliant name
for a satellite that discovered a comet
and neo-wise is the the uh
way that i think of andy neal because he
was so new and so young
and yet so wise so with that i'll say
i do to andy and uh my best wishes to
all uh his family and my condolences
a deep mind loving husband
a good friend and
it would have been nice to have a whole
lot more a whole lot more andy friedman
go thou forth and be cr be curious
be critical criticize
but be curious and help make the
civilization that he wanted
i feel so lucky to have called
andy friedman a friend and a colleague
at the clark center
and i still
you know can't believe that we don't
have him with us
and that we don't have many more years
of
talking about future projects and coming
up with
ideas for new programs and and just
having the kind of warm funny
delightful conversations he was known
for
you know after a clark center event or
or over some rubios on campus
so i just want to you know again send my
my deepest condolences to kristen
and to andy's parents and to everyone in
his family
and all of us uh in
academia and the world of science
that mourn his loss and
and miss his his warm-heartedness his
expansive imagination his willingness to
collaborate and entertain
wild ideas and uh
and you know especially for us with
clark as our namesake
just how much joy and inspiration he
took from science fiction
um but from all of the arts and in music
um especially and this is a
poem that i call prediction uh and then
dedicated to andy
if choice were an illusion you were
always going to go
entangled as it were as you were with
the stars
but still this spooky action living on
like ghosts in our expectant selves
of experiments to be designed questions
to be explored
revisions to be made to our version of
the cosmic story
but also lunches and tacos
traded jokes and books and never enough
time
it's there in the last conversation
your voice a hushed energy the idea of
starting a family
the first step toward having one gone
stories are always being revised
i don't want yours to be rewritten i
like the earlier draft
i prefer to imagine it unschooling in a
multiverse next door
where you pass an old man with the kiss
of a great grandchild on your cheek that
even you
could never have predicted
in this world i settle for something
unscientific
the thought of your soul a dandelion
scattered in a solar wind
your journey not over you only beginning
to explore
you are the open loophole you are the
dark matter
you aren't gone you are only the
embodiment of non-locality
an emblem of the star's story on the
nature of their hidden most
heart and the open spaces between its
words
you are the novum there teasing the
nature
of possibility the ink of the inkling
of the story to come and we
are waiting and we are listening
godspeed andy
you